from shock to anger
the military coup in myanmar has sparked
public displays of outrage
with people banging pots and pans
overnight in its biggest city
yangon two days after the takeover that
ousted ausang su chi
and her government calls for civil
disobedience mostly online
are growing doctors and nurses in at
least 30 towns have gone on strike to
oppose the coup
an act of defiance with potentially
dangerous consequences
and a country with one of south asia's
highest coronavirus death tolls
but they're still reluctant to protest
openly
some analysts say what happens over the
next week could define
the country's political future for years
to come
right now i don't know if people
are planning something big you know but
if
my guess is that if we go from the past
either this happens in the next four or
five days
or it'll just cool down military
vehicles now line the streets of major
cities
in a country still adapting after years
of military rule where dissidents were
silenced and opponents arrested
protests carry high risks on wednesday
morning the government-run newspaper
published a warning
urging people to not oppose the coup
at the moment people are buying the
newspapers to know the latest but i
don't think they'll keep buying it later
on
when photographs of military leaders
begin to appear on the cover
some say it's disgusting to see
myanmar's elected leader and head of the
national league for democracy on
seongsuchi
won a landslide victory in elections in
november
following a large loss of parties
favored by the military
it declared the election fraudulent now
the head of the army is running the
country
amid mounting international criticism
people are now wondering whether their
country's brief experience of democracy
has perhaps come to an end katya
lopezudayan
al jazeera ali is one of the few foreign
journalists based in myanmar she joins
us now live via skype from
yangon so police have filed charges
against aung san tsuchi and the
president
what have they charged them with ali
well aung san tsuchi has been charged
under the import
export act for apparently um being in
possession of communications equipment
now the import export act is incredibly
broadly written it's
notorious under the former military
regime for creating political prisoners
um and it was thought that when aung san
tsuchi's party
came into power they might revoke or or
um at least reform a lot of these laws
and this is definitely one of the most
notorious ones so they're
presumably kicking themselves now that
they didn't prioritize that
and and there were a lot of questions
about why they have
what hadn't addressed that because it's
left them vulnerable now
in this situation and they are and the
president he's been charged
under the um natural disasters act
on for breach of covet rules that's
thought to refer to a time during the
election campaign
elections uh campaigning was officially
banned because
of code restrictions gatherings of more
than 30 people
were were not allowed and a
convoy of cars and motorbikes drove past
his house
and he came out to greet them so he's
essentially being
um charged for that which is it seems
faintly ridiculous i mean both of the
charges are ridiculous but it seems
mainly ridiculous especially in
in light of the last few weeks where
we've seen daily
protests from pro-military groups
gathering in dozens or hundreds in the
last few days
um and without any kind of um
crackdown or any kind of uh
repercussions on them
and generally the covert restrictions
here have been
widely disregarded and there has really
been no response to that so it does seem
like they're picking and choosing
they're looking for excuses
they're using these very broadly written
laws or
laws that aren't really enforced to try
and find an excuse to keep them
under uh remand or in custody long
enough
i think to find more against them we
heard already that
they've raided the nld offices they're
probably
going to look through that sort of
information a lot of draconian
laws still on the books here that can
charge people for
for many different things so likely
they'll find something there
also the the uec the union election
commission
which was widely criticized by the
military
for um allegations of fraud the
military's making allegations for
against them they've been disbanded
the military has already in the last two
days created their own
uec and they're now investigating fraud
allegations
against many nld members so it's likely
we'll see more charges come from math as
well
aung san tsuchi remains hugely popular
in
the country as we heard earlier there is
a campaign of civil disobedience
how is the public likely to react to her
continued detention and these charges
well it's definitely going to provoke
more anger i think
as as the days have gone by and people
have had a bit more time to digest
that initial fear and anxiety here and
shock
has turned to sadness and now to anger
and and um defiance really and that's
what we're seeing today
in these campaigns for civil
disobedience uh we've
heard already about the hospital workers
who are refusing to work there
working their staff from government
hospitals what they're
essentially saying is we will not work
under the military
and they're trying to show the military
that without the people's support and
cooperation
the country won't function but it's a
risky game and it's interesting to see
how this will develop we don't know
whether we'll see people
coming to the streets we know from
myanmar's military
the military in myanmar's actions in the
past
what crackdowns on popular uprisings can
look like we saw it in 2007
we saw it in 1988 they can crack down
hard in violent
deadly deadly responses to popular
uprisings so it's possible
that this is a new approach or it's
possible that they're just biding their
time
to to wait and and respond when more
information about what's really going to
happen don sansoji comes out
ali fal reporting live there from yangon
ali many thanks indeed